Tarragona president gomez poor responder
detrimental sinner - Todd opal orange el
rey de gracias para Vera's a predator
realmente Perez de estado so programa de
fa to enforce new Tavo Co in el
sacrificio tris mesmo que ellos
consiguen comment Christmas MEK tambon
continuous Aruna pillow mir solidary dad
canto dinero para esto los soldados
co-respondent responsibili SNC ah Numa
union-leader a mint digna des no
tomorrow see rap and rock allocation
committee Posey Pardo Parliament a Josef
dole parle en France if local DJ absalom
all a commission to new absalom Oh c'est
le principe legality digital valley
treaty Offit Newsome La Diva
an gonna feel c'mon guarantee Oh Don
Santino event with eatin on certain key
so known as Anejo certain keen so
pysanka CR tank envelope as yet oh c'mon
guarantee la flexibility necessary some
cred la stratification son crazier she
son tanto que no sufism parte de la mama
no la commission Khan Gardi and a treaty
obligation definiteiy do not reproach a
continual Alafaya
a donkey agin ground Chris polity eva
demand a bunker intelligence
beaucoup dosages sell guarantee unity
amento compare may in diversity pass
clergy de carava conceive a roasted MC
party Lemkin co mm con some decorum OCD
roasted em disc le pas de coeur avec moi
coup de vous voir in playground antic
ratio Dolezal oh ho soprano savant
present a the blueprint to in veritable
in your economic monetary elephants
kuzava
a mysterious Todd sun-lee Paco's Avvo
Papa Zulu see don't simply print em
reprint oh sweet particular mo Fiero
lotro Honda primo philosophy hope MC
jürgen Habermas a DK uske presence
Estella presentation Opry complete
political Avenue globe tsukumo claw
commission a present a new continue halt
develop a fashion progressive maybe
ensue have exit vision la vision quino's
omen no salma on term the minimum care
is it a havi Dwarka rapprochement tula
group considered a priority on term
reconstruction le proposition key social
a table the Tamil mechanism reduce
unique kook
my greatest fear horns upin six o'clock
rarity on tablet as you may know see
Sookie via a prayer in your bunker on
the widget air your own term you see the
gist journalist on the whole
men on Tara you know politic and I think
the point during this debate for me more
instinct I was this one many of you
focus on the problems
others focus on the solutions I prefer
to be on the side of the solutions this
is the question I think the assessment
my assessment was realistic I have
recognized that there are still
difficulties I have not said that we are
out of the crisis
I've explicitly said that we are yet in
the crisis and that we should avoid any
kind of complacency but regarding the
situation we have two possibilities we
have the possibility to insist on the
negative side to continue this
self-depreciation
and this euro pessimism that is so
destructive that sometimes these
intellectually glamorous but that will
not bring hope and confidence to our
citizens or we can as European leaders
and you are as I am a European leader we
can give people hope and we can say to
them look there are indeed some signals
because there are some signals that
things are
for the better and this is the point and
this is the political question I put to
all of you at the beginning of my
intervention today and then I want to
address myself more directly to the pre
rup reinforces those that share as mr.
Svoboda said rightly some from the
center left some from the center right
some from the center but basically we
share the same values what is going to
be your story to the electors are you
going to say like the bottles or the xme
said everything is wrong in Europe I
think that if you go that way you will
only reinforce those who do not believe
as we believe in European values mr.
Callender you said making a joke about
possible competitors for the Commission
election that you are not interesting
that job that you are very happy to
yours
let me tell you very frankly that I
think even if you were interests you
could not have a chance to be like that
for president of the Commission and and
you know why I'm not saying that happily
because I think increasingly your party
and your group is looking like the you
keep and the aro skeptic and the
European group and I start to have some
doubts that you are going to be like in
yourself in Britain if it's not you keep
that is going to be the first force in
the British elections because when it
comes to be against Europe you when it
comes to be against Europe the people
prefer between the original and the copy
they prefer the original that's probably
why they are going to vote more for mr.
Faraj then for mr. Cullinan and this I
don't say with any kind of satisfaction
because we have even if we have some
differences we have worked in many areas
very constructive with conservatives the
British conservatives and the
conservative group we have worked
together for the internal market for
reform we have worked together against
some kind of regulation we have worked
together in many areas including free
trade but this is an important point I
think
because if those forces that are propane
or even those that are not really
prepared but constructive have the same
speech the same political attitude of
the anti Europeans the arrow skeptics
the populist in that case they will win
next election so my appeal to you is to
make the case for Europe because you are
part of Europe as I've said many of
legislation that was done it would not
be possible without the very strong
cooperation between the Commission and
the European Parliament the MFF we were
not happy with the result but frankly
without the complicity between the
Commission European power the result
will be much much lower present Schulz
knows that well because we were together
during that the good those negotiations
and I could give you many more examples
misses arms when you say that Europe has
done nothing or that in climate change
there is zero come on let's be real
Europe is leading in terms in the world
in terms of the objective for climate
change about co2 carved cars the
proposals were put forward by the
Commission if you are not satisfied with
the solution now ask the question to the
Member States top to the Commission we
are keeping a very strong commitment to
climate change Mr Farage shows that
populist are sometimes obscure on tests
99% of the science Mr Farage believes
that his climate change exists reduce
result of human activity ninety-nine
percent of scientists of course there
are always some people that are paid to
say the opposite but I to pretend as you
pretend that against all science well
some science that the problem of climate
change is just an invention of the
greens or of the left it's completely
nonsense of course we have to find a way
of course we have to find a sensible way
to do to fight climate change we have to
look at the same time for comparing us
in Europe we have to make this part of
our agenda for growth and I believe that
green economy brings many possibilities
it will be a mistake just to put the
case on climate change on environmental
matter
that's of course decisive it's an easy
stencil thing for our planet the
conservation of our planet but we have
to make the case also in terms of the
economy in terms of what it can bring
and to attempt about health because in
fact we have seen increasingly natural
disasters that most scientists attribute
to climate change so this is important
and I think I think that is almost
incredible that the leader of one
european parliament group says like that
that it is an invention of some
political forces something that has been
established clear by science and i as
I've said before I believe in science
and I believe part of the solution for
our problems is for more science few
more science more innovation more
research more technology and this is the
way for Europe to address these problems
regarding the social aspect mr. Svoboda
you know very well that Europe has been
fighting a lot for this matter at least
European institutions you know very well
that the European Commission was pushing
hard for a more generous social fund for
the globalization adjustment fund for
the financial transaction text yet now
some Member States do not want to to
implement you know very well so let's
not create here artificial divisions now
what happens in fact is that we are
aware of the difficulties in Europe you
are right you and some others when you I
like that many of our citizens namely
unemployed people are still living and
to run one of the distinguished members
of the Parliament that said to me that I
have never seen that reality that I have
never seen people as beggars here near
the Parliament let me tell you not only
I've seen people near the Parliament but
together with Joseph dull I went to a
balcony monter a food bank in the region
of Strasbourg Behar and I know well how
many people are poor in Europe and
suffer coming from my country Portugal I
know well the difficulties of poverty in
many of our sectors
but not only I know I'm fighting to
solve that problem
it was the Commission who kept their
ambition for a fund for the most
deprived people and we had to fight a
lot against some capitals that were
pretending to put it out of our
priorities so not only we know the
reality in Europe but we are trying to
do our best with the instruments we have
to remedy those situations and this is
the point I want to make as well because
as was said by some of you where are the
instruments many of these their
instruments and responsibilities are at
national level let's be honest
employment is mainly a national policy
we can influence we can create some
funds we can create new user employment
initiative we took the initiative of the
u.s. guarantee but at the end it depends
on what Member States do or do not do
this is the point and that's why we have
to be clear about this because if not
and you are going to see that during the
elections many of our citizens are going
to put the blame on Europe for what was
indeed action or inaction of some of our
governments and member states that's the
tendency to Europeanized the final and
to nationalise success and I believe
that you as members of the Parliament
and we as European Commission we have a
duty to explain to our citizens
what is the national responsibility what
is European responsibility of course
having an honest and reasonable
assessment of course recognizing also
that not everything we have been doing
is perfect of course recognizing that
sometimes it's frustrating this slow
decisions of the Member States and the
European Union architecture but giving
help to our citizens I think that as
political leaders we have the duty of
confidence we have a duty to provide
help to our citizens and that is my
appeal to you namely to the pro European
forces that I believe that in spite of
some ideological differences share the
same values the same values that are in
the Treaty of Lisbon that have been
there since the Treaty of Rome the
values of the dignity of human being of
peace of freedom and justice and that is
why
was also happy to receive the words of
many of you congratulating the
commission by what we are doing in terms
of rule of law because if you want to
speak about rule of all internationally
we have to be sure that here in Europe
we also respect all those principles
because our conception of Europe is not
just about economy or about a market is
a conception based on values and I
believe that in spite of the detrol
differences we basically share these
these values and I have a great
confidence in Europe I think that was
mrs. McGinnis gave some figures about
the extraordinary support that still
exists in Europe to the European ideal
don't you find really extraordinary that
in spite of all the difficulties that
the Greek citizens have been knowing a
huge majority of Greek citizens supports
the euro
don't you find extraordinary that in in
Spain even if there are 5 million non
Spanish unemployed there is not a party
sign of fabric or ante foreigners I
believe that in Europe we have a great
resilience I believe that this crisis
has tested us and it's testing us to the
limit and I believe that in Europe if
you keep the objectives we will get out
of this crisis stronger because our
resilience was tested it's a completely
caricature to present European policy
just fiscal consolidation at least since
2010 that I have been saying that fiscal
cost reduction alone is not sufficient
that there are some limits to the policy
of fiscal consolidation our policy is a
complex mix of fiscal consolidation
structural reform and investment
targeted investment in the sectors of
the future to have a more innovative and
more modern Europe and even in fiscal
consolidation we have been adapting to
the different difficult economic cycle
the Commission has been put born and
been putting much more emphasis on the
stroke
deficit then on the nominal deficits as
you know and it was our proposal in
several cases to propose to to give the
member states more time to adjust their
deficits so trying to find the right
balance and the right collaboration for
a policy that of course as in the medium
term in the iminium in the short term as
naturally researchers recessionary
effect but the question once again to
say the question is who is responsible
for the difficulties in Europe is this
policy or was the mistakes made in the
past one of you said Greece is the
victim of the policies of Europe false
completely Greece is the victim of the
responsible behavior of the governments
of Greece this is the reality and it was
because of that that European nose asks
to come and support without your opinion
and support Greece will be now
completely solvent the situation will be
much more difficult so we have to have
the courage to say who created the
problem new Europe without European
Union the countries that are now in a
difficult situation will be in a much
worse situation without nearly will be
suffering much more and so this is
important to put the record straight
because if not our electors your
electors will think that Europe is to
blame when in fact as I said Europe even
if it's not perfect Europe has not
created the problem Europe is a victim
of the problem and Europe is certainly
part of the solution I thank you for
your attention